hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again we
have another short dev stream today kind
of makes you wonder when we're actually
gonna get some decent info but but we
didn't just get nothing today we got
actually some interesting stuff like new
content of the week which I'll be
covering and probably showing on screen
because it's a little bit long as well
as some DDoS attack rewards and stuff
like that so as always liked if you do
enjoy subscriber for a new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch what's in the leaks so
when we kept up to date with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
so first up I'm pretty sure this is
gonna be the longer section of the video
so I will be showing this right now but
we have the new content of the week it
is signature so we finally got some new
content to purchase if we like I do have
to admit some of them are really good
gladiator new Shivalik and JJ are some
of my favorites especially Nobu she's
definitely gonna be getting gladiators
I'm gonna hop on today and but the
problem is that some of them are
actually identical like hito carries if
you go to hit to a curious signature
there's two of them that look completely
identical one of them being this new one
so I'm not really sure what the hell is
going on here with this but regardless
most of the characters has some unique
signatures but as for the other stuff
there is a little bit of fixes with
revenge this was a small title update
that went live today which is why if you
couldn't play for like 30 minutes this
is why revenge was fixed in certain
moves that have to do with throw moves
like caber toss a long arm etc so that
will be fixed there's also going to be a
new event order which is the faction
with the most amount of ranked wins will
win and then also that the bundle from
the hito kiri event is still alive and
it will be still alive until July first
and there's also going to be a new
arcade quest as usual and then lastly is
the compensation for the DDoS attacks so
like I think for like a couple days ago
or something like that or something
happen with Ubisoft where they got
ddosed and it happened throughout like a
period of a month or some type [ __ ] so
as a reward for that for us not being
able to play we are going to beginning
250 steal and 3 XP boosts so a absurdly
low amount of steal and a decent amount
of XP boosts let me know your thoughts
on that I feel like we should be getting
more steel but maybe I'm just too great
yeah other than that those really ate
about the stream they did show in art
contest and I got to give a shout out to
my boy fragment always post some really
good art they showed his on stream today
here's it's from the heat of hearing
event and stuff like that so he's gonna
be getting some type of prize so
excellent work there mate yeah guys and
that's really it there's really not much
else to talk about hopefully within
these next week or two that we may have
something to talk about in terms of this
new character currently we're still
within the campaign so we haven't really
got much this is really like that end
it's I call it still the end season of
the off season though even though it's
really not because usually after an
event is over there's really not much
after the event and then till after the
season is over so cuz we're kind of in
that middle ground there it's gonna get
probably a lot boring not a whole lot of
content being shown stuff like that but
I'm hoping that it will at least you
know will at least get maybe a teaser or
something throughout these next couple
weeks yeah but let me know in the
comments below on a scale of one to ten
how hyped you are for this biking hero I
feel like he's gonna be overhyped as
[ __ ] and be garbage but I'm still gonna
be hype regardless saw him and give that
a fat ten so let me know in the comments
below
loud to start a discussion with you yeah
I like the view if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the Patchett's and the leaks if
you want to be kept up-to-date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe to the
channel and with that my two most videos
gonna be on the screen that take care
guys enjoy the rest your day and peace
out
[Music]